And as some of you may know, Donald Trump's
lawyer, Rudy Giuliani, has been hospitalized
with covid for a few days. Rudy behaved completely
irresponsibly for the last month. He's been flying
around the country doing indoor so-called voter
fraud hearings. No mask. So he caught the virus.
A Trump lawyer, John Ellis, also caught the
virus. Rudy was reportedly convinced by Donald
Trump's doctor, Sean Connelly. Go to the hospital.
Just go, go, go. Because reportedly Sean Connelly
said to Rudy, we can deal with this in
three days and then you'll be good to go.
And then from the hospital earlier this week,
Rudy was speaking out against masks and social
distancing guidelines. I mean, the irony, while
he's in a hospital getting treatment and we later
found out Rudy Giuliani received Ramdas severe and
dexamethasone as treatment, Rudy was interviewed
on New York talk radio station Seventy-Seven
ABC, and he said, listen, we have treatments.
This is OK. Listen, they give you medications
and you improve. Let's not overreact. Let's not
go crazy with masks and social distancing.
And when the host pointed out, you know,
the protocol you've received in particular and
severe, except in certain cases where you qualify
for it without paying, that's too expensive for
most Americans. Every American can't get Ramdas,
Suvir and Rudy said, oh, we'll I don't know.
I mean, you know, they gave it to me here at
this hospital and he said, I don't know that
it's true that not everybody can get this.
When Trump came out of coronavirus, he was
also saying, don't be. These are quotes,
don't be afraid of it. Don't let it dominate your
life. We have treatments. It might even be a cure.
And of course, Donald Trump received dexamethasone
for low oxygen, which is not expensive. But again,
you have to be in a place where you're being
monitored very closely, where as soon as you
get low oxygen, you get the decks. He got five
days of severe. Trump got the experimental
antibody treatment from Regeneron. This is not
available to all patients. It's available to rich
and or privileged patients or celebrity patients.
So Rudy is thinking, I don't know, I got this.
I just went to the hospital. I've got a three
doctor team monitoring me and the top treatments.
What's the big deal? And this is exactly the
point, people connected to reality understand that
this is a two tiered system in the United States.
Now, Rudy did say he doesn't think he would even
have gone to the hospital this soon were he not
well known or a celebrity. So he in that same
interview, he seemed to recognize, you know, I
think I'm here because I'm a celebrity. I don't
know that that I would even be here. But he's
unaware of the fact that even when hospitalized,
not everybody can get the treatment that he
got. And this is the reality. American health
care is really good for the privileged and the
wealthy. People even come from other countries
here to get specific treatments or procedures.
Even for people living in one part of the country
versus another. It can be a significantly
better health care system. But for huge
swaths of the population, it's a disastrous
system. At the same time, you know, again,
he Rudy acknowledges he's there because he's
a celebrity, but he seems to think anybody,
anybody would get the get the treatment. Most
people are told stay home if it gets really bad,
come in. When you go in, it's packed and you
have one doctor for 20 patients rather than
three doctors for one celebrity patient. Now,
it's quite possible that even if Rudy Giuliani
knew that not everybody could get the same
treatment, he still might not have a different
perspective on what should be done. But this is
like the height of of plutocracy. It's less that,
you know, I have no problem with Rudy getting what
he's getting. It's that everybody should be able
to get it and they can't ramdas severe.
It would even be a dosing issue. I mean,
there's not that much of it available and Rudy
seems completely clueless about that piece of it.
Folks like Rudy don't understand what these things
cost, whether the average American can afford it.
Think back to my appendectomy last year. I
have insurance with a two thousand dollar
annual deductible for hospitalization, large
procedures, E.R., that type of thing. So
when I went in, not even knowing yet that
I had appendicitis, but suspecting it,
I knew I could be responsible for up to two
thousand bucks. I could come out hours later
and oh, two thousand dollars. And when they
started with the CT scan and the IV drips and
then said, you have appendicitis, you're having
surgery, I anticipated I'm going to go to grand
here now. I always have in my mind I have a two
thousand dollar deductible at any time I fall and
break an ankle or I get whatever I could owe. Two
thousand dollars. I have the two thousand dollars.
It's OK. I had the privilege of knowing, you
know what? I'll go to a top hospital. Brigham
and Women's have a great surgeon, great care,
and then I'll owe two grand and then I'll pay
for it. And that's great. Half the country can't
meet an unexpected four hundred dollar expense
with insurance. They would not be able
to meet the deductible. And my deductible
isn't even that high. Lots of folks with high
deductible plans might have a four or five,
six or seven thousand dollar deductible to meet
before their insurance kicks in. And meanwhile,
Rudy thinks you show up, they give you the decks,
they give you a room severe. Three doctors are
checking in on me and it's all really, really
great. This is part of the problem. A lot of the
people claiming it's no big deal are the people
who have access to that. At the drop of a pin,